de notre pays vouloir élever le niveau
c'est évidemment aussi lutter contre les
cours perdus pour les élèves l'an
dernier il y a 15 millions d'heures de
cours qui n'ont pas été honorés pour les
élèves 15 millions d'heures d'absence
non remplacé on peut pas ambitionner
d'élever le niveau avec 15 millions
d'heures de cours perdu sur une année
j'ai fait de ce sujet une priorité sur
ces 15 millions d'heures perdu la moitié
sont lié à l'organisation de notre
système et donc il faut éviter les
absences évitables en repositionnant les
épreuves de spécialité du mois de mars
Au mois de juin nous récupérons des
heures qui étaient perdues à cause de
l'organisation des examens j'ai assumé
j'assume le choix de positionner
désormais la formationue des enseignants
en dehors du temps de classe je dis pas
en dehors du temps scolaire et
uniquement sur les vacances mais en tout
cas en dehors du temps de classe c'est
près de 2 millions d'heures de cours
l'an dernier qui ont été perdu du fait
de temps de formation des enseignants
sur le temps de la classe pour ce qui
est des absences qu'on ne peut pas
éviter il y en aura évidemment toujours
dans une administration 1200000 agents
il n faut améliorer notre capacité de
remplacement c'est donc pour répondre à
votre deuxième question sur le pacte
enseignant puisque vous savez le pacte
vise à mieux rémunérer mieux soutenir
les les enseignants qui s'engagent
notamment dans le remplacement de courte
durée il y en a déjà beaucoup qui
s'engageaient dans le remplacement de
courte durée ces années précédentes en
heures supplémentaires ils seront
désormais rémunérés 50 % de plus pour
ces missions qu'ils effectuent déj
jusqu'à l'année dernière un enseignant
qui faisait du remplacement de courte
durée était rémunéré je crois 41 € brut
de l'heure avec le PACT enseignant ça
passe à 70 € brut de l'heure
augmentation très importante